like if you can pull up that article I'm
I'm you know it's a topic we haven't
reacted to and had a conversation about
yet uh you guys obviously heard this
Alex Jones ordered to pay 965 million
dollars uh for the Sandy Hook uh lies
until the political right argues this
movement from its ranks none of this
ends Senator Chris Murphy
um 965 and the way they came up with
this number is to say that he used Sandy
Hook to make a lot of money for himself
so the families are the judges ordering
him to pay 965 million dollars
this can go to anybody when you first
heard this number I mean I understood
some number was going to come out but
when you heard this number 965 what was
the initial reaction
that's a lot of money
so as well
that's a lot of money Tom what was your
reaction when you saw this I I think the
uh the verdict there and the penalty
phase is political grandstanding
um basically what they're saying is is
whoever you are you know
um and let's set it set Alex's sins
aside and what they're saying is whoever
you are if we don't like you and you
stand up to the scrutiny and you lose in
this forum we're gonna take everything
from you yeah that's the message that's
being played out here set aside the
things that Alex did well Alex didn't do
well the people that believe Alex the
people that don't
set aside all that this is a political
message that says we now have a
precedent and if we don't like you and
we can take you to the mat in court we
will take everything from you
I mean for me this comes down to
um everything that's kind of been in the
political circles for the last five ten
years is what's the truth and what's
just fake news and this is as fake news
as it gets as far as Alex Jones and the
Sandy Hook lie and he's paying the
ultimate price for a massive massive
to be blunt like horrible shitty lie
um and I zero percent support Alex Jones
in this Arena on this with that being
said again not a fan of Alex Jones
what he did is disgusting but that
doesn't mean that other things he says
are now untrue right like you're gonna
have to kind of separate this horrible
lie that he's gonna have to pay the
price for forever billion dollars almost
and then he doesn't have other things he
has to say which may or may not be true
or false I don't know but this was a
very very bad lie and he's paying the
price for it now there's been a lot of
giant verdicts like this in history That
No One Believes that pennies are ever
going to be transferred you know yeah
I'm sure he doesn't have 965. it's a
completely different thing but OJ lost
the Civil the civil suit and you know
even pawning off his Heisman Trophy and
all now that's much different I mean a
crime was committed there he lost that
suit but he you know but the Goldman's
never got back tens of millions of
dollars for their legal fees and
everything else in the loss of their
daughter she knows sometimes when when
you go ahead you were gonna say
something I was gonna say uh random note
so Alex Jones and myself connection uh
we were just both on the best seller
list so now I was uh number six uh like
USA Today in Wall Street Journal a
couple weeks back and I looked on it
Alex Jones had the I think number one
book number two book at that time he
needs to sell a billion copies yeah
what did the Bible's ever sold to pay
this in terms of pure money what happens
with is he ever gonna pay this is he
bankrupt does he how does how does this
how does this work follow the money
no idea first of all this is this is uh
uh I have some thoughts on this and this
is what my thoughts are you know how
sometimes
um somebody you hate which this is on a
list of a person that a lot of people
hate I mean this this guy's
hated by the people on the left many
liberals cannot stand this guy in their
glad he got this and there are people
that think this wasn't enough there are
some that would like to see this guy go
to jail and spend time in jail for the
rest of his life many people can't stand
this guy having said that
there are a lot of people right now that
you know they're sitting on what they're
thinking they're sitting there saying uh
oh shoot I told a lot Eliza at CNN oh my
God what is this all about I mean
believe me I can't stand this guy but
dude
965 million are you out of your mind
like you know when the metoo movement
came out and in Hollywood first person
got the metoo movement you all of a
sudden saw a lot of players a lot of big
names are like let me not attend the
next party and those pictures that were
taken with me at a party with this guy
named you know uh what's his name
Epstein Epstein whatever the guy's name
is I've never been with that guy
anywhere right so so the moral of the
story is the final one
how they came up with the number they're
claiming he made this amount of money
okay fine number two if the standard is
now that a person who's got opinions
lies you sue them well let me tell you
there's a there's a lot of people in
media that are about to get sued heavily
by a lot of families that were that were
affected by things like this and it
ain't gonna be pretty don't get me wrong
I'm not sitting here defending uh what
he said or what he didn't say that's not
my position my position is the following
Remington got sued last year
for 73 million dollars that they paid
you know for what for somebody else
using a Remington gun to kill somebody
they loved and the family got 73 million
dollars I don't know if you guys saw
this or not San Diego family settled for
73 million dollars with gun maker
Remington what did Remington do wrong
but here here's the other part if you go
a little bit deeper if you go go a
little lower so we can read the article
can you zoom in a little bit more so the
families are nine victims San Diego
Tuesday have agreed to uh 73 million out
of settlement loss with the model maker
rifle used to kill the okay of a lawsuit
against the maker of the rifle used to
kill 20 first graders and six Educators
in 2012. okay the case was watched
closely by gun control Advocates and gun
rights supporters and manufacturers
because of its potential to provide a
roadmap for victims of other shootings
to sue firearm makers this has got
nothing to do with guns in my eyes this
has got nothing to do with guns and
mites can you do me a favor can you go
pull up how many people got killed by a
car accident last year how many people
died from a car accident last year so
doesn't this set the precedent for
somebody to be able to sue a car maker
to say my loved one
died by the car that you made so you
made but what do you mean I didn't drive
it I understand but you made this Ford
Focus you made this Tesla it's like it's
like wakusha or uh Wisconsin the guy
drove the Ford through the parade so now
you're making the case that you could go
sue for it you can go this guy forward
because yes the Explorer through the
parade that's what they wanted to avoid
here the reason Remington settles for 73
million dollars which I I can pretty
much I'm gonna go out on a guess here at
their corporate Insurance paid that
right to get the settlement they say
listen we'll drop the suit and settle
but you're my insurance company you got
to pay the 73 they're like done here's
what we don't want we don't want the
legal precedent there's no precedent
here there's a precedent of settlement
but there's no legal binding precedent
do you see so there is no court case to
go back to as a as a hard legal
precedent that is a disaster if you're a
gun maker or a car maker or anybody that
uses something so Remington and I think
used insurance money here said let's get
this thing out of the headlines let's
finish this thing up and let's get out
what's the alternative if they don't say
they say we're not going to do it they
go all the way and they have a risk of a
of a crazy liberal jury you know handing
down a legal precedent
and then basically it becomes just like
those class action asbestos lawsuits
buckle up everybody was ever nearly you
see the asbestos ads that are on
everywhere on new shows from 6 a.m to 9
A.M I I don't know I don't once you have
a legal precedent that's what you get
you get class I get that but you know
what happened with Candace Owens
yesterday with a documentary that came
out did you hear about this that
happened that uh uh George Floyd's
family they're considering suing them
for the black lives matter documentary
that she made right there click on that
story write their trending news so
George Floyd's family feels betrayed by
Kanye West as they considered soon
rapper and Candace Owens after Kanye
West falsely claimed George Floyd died
from fentanyl uh uh and not an officer's
knee on his neck the family's lawyer
says by the end of the week we'll see
we'll have at least an idea of what
claims are valuable go a little lower go
a little lower so now uh an attorney for
the family
Connor's 46 year old uh attorney Lee
Merritt confirms to Rolling Stone that
the Fallout family is considering
Persona legal case against a rapper and
say that he is also looking into whether
Ultra right-wing Panda Candace owns
could be held liable as well since West
has plucked the debunked claim over her
new daily wire produced documentary the
greatest live or sold this is the whole
BLM thing and while Merit acknowledges
that there's no real grounds to pursue a
defamation claim on behalf of the
deceased person he says he the near one
billion dollar judgment that Sandy Hook
parents there you go Bingo that's a new
parents won against Infowars Alex Jones
spreading conspiracies press presents a
possible pathway for legal recourse but
not a not a decision precedent I I
understand that but baton 965 73 million
this could be the new thing that people
are going to see this I agree go there
and just get a settlement they will most
likely settle with you because they
don't want to drag anything out
um my daily wire has the kind of a legal
liability insurance that Remington has
well and I also have or you said you
hope I doubt because the the member of
the United States the insurance is
always the pocket you go after well and
let's not forget that George Floyd had
enough fentanyl in his system to kill a
horse so they don't have a case here he
did he did have enough there were two
different autopsies done on George Floyd
one of which said he died of a drug
overdose the second one said he died of
a knee on the neck and let's not forget
there was a nine minute tape of the knee
on the neck there was nine minutes
before that of George Floyd walking
around you could tell he was under the
influence of drugs you could tell all
these things so this these are this is
not an Apples to Apples comparison daily
wire could actually make a case here I
doubt they would lose this one but but I
was or settle I understand what you're
saying so Jones provides the precedent
for them to go out all I'm saying is
people are looking at this and they're
like
oh my God let me go get some money
there's free money there let me there's
let me go straight let me go through
this guy I agree this is becoming you
know a for for folks who I remember one
time I was at an event George Will was
speaking and George well this is at
Miramar Hotel Santa Monica 2000 and uh
I'll give you the date exact date March
20 something of 2009 and he gets up and
he says do you know why these hook you
know fishing hook companies you know how
they sell the hook and why they have to
put a warning sign on it now because a
parent sued one of the companies saying
you didn't put a sign on they're saying
you shouldn't swallow my kid swallowed
it and it hurt his belly so they sued
the company he says do you know why so
many parks in America are being shut
down because lawyers go sit there and
watch a kid fall and break their hands
and they're suing the city and they're
getting money out of it because cities
are settling so they're saying hey get
rid of the parks we're getting too many
of these losses so kids are now obesity
is going higher these types of lawyers
many times ruin a lot of different good
things so you have to know like going
back to the same thing with McDonald's
Hot Coffee case
I I'm not comfortable with this man I'm
not comfortable with this I think a lot
of people are just so happy and they're
litigious and they're going to look at
going after a lot of different people
and many are going to settle because
they have the pockets but Alex Jones
does not have 965 million so I got a
point on this so in my ordeal I had some
media some Publications in my book that
ran not only you know we we hate Stuart
scheller or their opinions but like
factually untrue things right and so I
actually looked into a defamation suit
and I was told that it would be very
hard to prove because I was considered a
public figure and so once I make the
videos and I'm a public figure I go into
a different class of legality so when
you think of Sandman that that kid with
the Trump hat or you think of uh Kyle
Rittenhouse they're private citizens so
when they sue these people it's
different than if Stuart tell her where
to sue them and the the lawsuit I've
talked to three different lawyers the
lawsuit all three of them brought up was
Sarah Palin suing some newspaper I can't
remember if it was the New York Times or
the Wall Street Journal but she sued
them because that paper alleged that she
had something to do with the school
shooting and she lost because she was
considered a public figure and so when
you're talking about New York Times yep
so when you're that that case right
there said a lot of precedent that like
if someone named Stuart scheller has a
YouTube video and it gets a million
views and then newspapers run factually
untrue things the lawyer's advice to me
is you're probably not going to win
because you're a public figure go look
at Sarah Palin and so you got to kind of
differentiate the cases here Sandy Hook
parents are considered individual people
they're not considered public figures
whereas Alex Jones is a public figure so
Alex Jones going to sue someone because
he got his feelings hurt it would be a
different level of legality that he
would have to get now where I don't know
where it stands George Floyd you know is
he a public figure or is his family a
public figure I don't know the answer to
that question but there is a delineation
there there's also the media is given
the uh the malice defense you know if
there's absence of malice hey we don't
we don't
hate Lieutenant former Lieutenant
Colonel Stuart scheller we were just
reporting the news yeah and the best
facts to the best of our ability that
was the news of the day and we were
reporting it and so that's referred to
as the absence of malice defense I mean
they compared me to Hitler in one of the
and you know I served my country for 17
years I mean some of the stuff they said
they and that's where the malice line
crosses so if when you make metaphors
that are inflammatory versus just
reporting it and then they hide behind
well you're a public figure that's right
but there is a line there is a line
there that they can't cross even the
media can't cross
even the media can't cross
what happened the last six years with
what a lot of these platforms media
companies they're talking about it's got
to be big enough it's got to be Stark
enough and you have to have enough
resources that you can take it all the
way here's a question here's a question
where when has a public figure won a
lawsuit against a news publication
like when's the last time that happened
I can't even think of one right and so
uh maybe maybe a viewer can in the
comment section drop that but I would
like to know because quite honestly the
media has it doesn't necessarily always
report
misinformation sometimes they just
report the information that they want
but when they say factually untrue
things like how are we holding them
accountable then that's where you know I
really started getting frustrated
through my ordeal because imagine a
marine officer that legally can't speak
in the media because he's under a gag
order and the media getting to say all
sorts of things some of them factually
untrue like there should be some type of
legal recourse that when we're talking
965 million you know what I mean and
then here I am and I'm not able to sue
anyone because I'm considered a public
figure seems weird you say the last time
that a public figure one won a lawsuit
against a news publication first thing
that comes to mind is that whole Gawker
Peter Thiel Hulk Hogan
whatever that whole thing was didn't
anyway wasn't that a thing yep and um it
wasn't a lawsuit but
um
the Bush Administration took Dan Rather
to the map and he got fired
yeah
the president I think has a little power
though
no no correct correct the point is it's
it happens but it's rare and if a news
media organization just says well we're
just reporting the news then they are
completely unassailable I mean you're
not going to be able to to to knock that
over you know but when you've got what
Gawker did with Hogan if you're willing
to go long enough and pay for it you can
you can go get it done but it's rare and
it's hard so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]